In this video, I'd like to show you an example of a Python testing tool,
which you can find within this project.
It's a good example of how Python can be integrated in, in a practical way.
You also might find it useful in writing scripts going further on in,
especially if you're not using your own IDE.
If you go down into the content browser,
you're going to find that there's an EUW underscore Python tester.
Again, this is an editor utility widget.
And if you right-hand click and go run editor utility widget,
you're going to see you get up this kind of small,
what is sort of a fake IDE.
Now, I find this a lot more useful than the output block.
So what it has is if you run a script,
you can just hit run and you can copy to take it out.
And there are a bunch of other settings.
Now, what's useful about this is you can run everything within the editor very quickly.
Secondly, I have a whole load of pre-written code,
which I've already tested.
So as I've got stuff to work,
I've come in here and I've saved them as pieces of code.
So for example, at the bottom, I have take screen shot with timestamp.
And if I clear the box and go add code.
Now, when I hit the run, it will take a screenshot,
which is quite useful.
But the code, I've all gone away and I figured out.
It also has a couple other bits of functionality.
So at the top, it has the query asset and the query actor.
So if I was to select,
for example, let's see if we've got anything for the player start.
You go query actor.
You can see it's giving us the reference here.
It will also open up a page to the player start so that we can look through it.
So what this works on is all we need to do is select anything within the browser.
So, for example, I think this is a static mesh,
go query actor, and that will bring up the static mesh actor section.
And if I select this, so it's going to give us an idea
of what our path is to the top level asset.
Now, actor is going to query stuff, which is in the viewport.
And then we have the equivalent for asset here.
So, for example, if I select material,
it's going to bring up material along with all of the different sort of settings
and it will bring up the web page directly.
So that's a sort of useful quick querier
so you can find out what you're working with.
Combined with that, it's got a whole load of different code here
that you can just access by pushing add code.
It will give you the different code.
Sometimes for comments, sometimes not.
Okay, so that's the first thing.
And I might use that to demonstrate elements as we're going forward.
And again, this is actually quite a good example of how you might make a tool.
So feel free to click on this button in the top right-hand corner,
which will open up the tool within UMG.
And you can come in here and you can view,
unfortunately not terribly well commented,
an example of putting together a tool.
So I hope you find that useful.
We might be referencing this in a couple of the further extra videos.
But that's it for the Python testing tool.